good morning John I am a bit worn out on
philosophical musings and to tell you
the truth a bit worn out in general
learning conferences is hard so today
instead of thinking too much about
things that people usually don't think
very much about I'm just gonna tell you
the fascinating tale of Phineas Gage in
1848 Phineas Gage was a hard-working
well-liked construction foreman working
on the railroad he was helping to blow
up the side of a mountain so that they
could run a railroad through it and this
is something he'd been doing for quite a
long time what you do is you drill a
hole into a rock and you put some
blasting powder in there and then you
put some sand in there to pack it down
then you pack it down with this rock so
Phineas was doing this and then someone
distracted him I don't know what it was
distracted maybe it was a raccoon maybe
it was a hot girl walking down the
railway but when Phineas came back to
his work he did not realize that he had
not put the sand in and so he shoved his
little rod down the hole creating a
spark and the blasting powder ignited
and his iron rod landed 80 feet away
unfortunately there was something in
between that hole and whatever it was
that was 80 feet away and that thing was
Phineas gages head the rod went through
about about here and came out like here
and now those of you who do not know the
story are expecting this story to end
because where could the story go from
there well three minutes later Phineas
Gage regained consciousness
started talking to people walked over to
a cart got in the cart sat up for the
3/4 mile travel back to his house waited
there for a doctor and then when the
doctor finally got there they chatted
about it the doctor took some wonderful
written notes which we have copies of
and I'm going to share some of that with
you though you may not want to listen if
you're a little bit squeamish the doctor
wrote I did not believe mr. gages
statement at the time but thought he was
deceived mr. gage persisted in saying
that the rod went through his head mr.
gage got up and vomited the effort of
the vomiting pushed about half a tea cup
full of brain which fell onto the floor
the unit of measurement tea cup full has
has since fallen out of use but but it's
roughly way too much brain and that same
visit Phineas said to the doctor that he
hoped he wasn't much hurt to which the
doctor presumably replied uh in the
coming weeks gage would drop in and out
of a coma caused by hemorrhaging in his
brain his family was assured that there
was no possible way that he could live
which is also backed up by you know
reason and they had his coffin and his
burial clothes already and then to
months after the accident Phineas Gage
was walking around talking basically a
normal guy he wasn't quite normal he
wasn't quite the Phineas Gage that
everyone had come to know and love but
on the whole a lot healthier than you
would expect from a guy who would lost
several t cupfuls of brain so because of
his behavioral problems Phineas Gage did
lose his construction job but PT Barnum
not to miss a weirdo found this guy in
his iron rod and Phineas did a little
tour the circuses earning some money
that way his psychological problems
began to subside he started holding down
good jobs and eventually he moved to
Chile to become a long-distance
stagecoach driver in a place where
people didn't know that he was Phineas
Gage 12 years after the accident late
onset epilepsy set in which is very
common in these kinds of injuries and
Phineas his health declined until he
finally died the man had a three and a
half foot long rod of iron pass through
his head at hundreds of miles per hour
he was pretty much okay for 12 years a
final footnote to this bizarre tale in
2009 a couple who loved to collect old
photographs of people we're scanning
their collection and uploading it to the
photo sharing website flicker they
uploaded a picture that they called the
whaler thinking that it was an injured
Whaler with his harpoon like her quickly
told them that there was no way that
that big shaft of iron was any kind of
harpoon but no one had any suggestions
about what else it could be until
somebody commented saying you know you
may have a picture of Phineas Gage there
and if you do it's the only picture of
Phineas Gage that exists and that's one
more reason why I love the internet
because it was the only picture of
Phineas Gage so Jon behold
Phineas Gage the only man to have ever
had an iron rod passed through his skull
at hundreds of miles per hour and live
to tell the tale I'll see you on
Wednesday